صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين امريكيه انه
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه سافر في وقت سابق من شهر يونيو
الى اوكرانيا
وتضمنت هذه زياره السريه
وكبار مسؤولي الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
واضاف المصدر ان المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
كشفوا عن استراتيجيتهم لاستعاده الاراضي
التي تحتلها روسيا وبدء مفاوضات وقف اطلاق
النار مع موسكو بحلول نهايه العامه
اما رئيس الوزراء الاسباني بيدروس فوصل
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه تعبيرا عن التضامن
الاوروبي مع اوكرانيا مع تولي اسبانيا
رئاسه الاتحاد الاوروبي قال ان بلاده
ستواصل تقديم الدعم للشعب الاوكراني حتى
يعود السلام في اوروبا وفق تعبير
كيف معنى الان مراسلنا عمر الحاج عمر اذن
ضعنا في صوره اخر الردود الفعل السياسيه
على ما يجري وهذه الزيارات لكييف
الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
نعم ليلى وعثمان كييف تنتظر مؤتمر الصحفيا
سيجمع رئيس الوزراء الاسباني مع الرئيس
الذي وصل صباح اليوم وقال ان اول عمل تريد
ان تبداه اسبانيا كرئيسه لمجد لمجلس
الاوروبي هو التعبير عن التضامن مع
اوكرانيا وان تبدا مهامها من كييف لتضمن
لتؤكد للشعب الاوكراني انها مع ان ان
المجلس الاوروبي معها حتى يعود السلام الى
اوروبا لكن ليس الوحيد الذي
وصل الى كيف في انتظار الان وصول رئيس
الوزراء
البريطاني
ريشي سوناك الذي قال الرئيس قبل يومين انه
سيصل الى كييف في هذا التاريخ وايضا
سيجتمع معه ومع كبار المسؤولين الاوكراني
وحتى الان برامج هذه الزيارات لاسباب
امنيه كما تعلمون معتم عليها ولا يتم
ابلاغ عنها الا بعد وقوعها ولا نعلم حتى
الان ان كان هناك مؤتمر صحفي ثلاثي
للزعماء ام انسكي سيكون له لقاءات ثنائيه
مع رؤساء الوزراء على حدا ومع الوفود
المشاركه معهم كنا نتحدث عن الزيارات ايضا
كان هناك زياره كما ذكرتم لرئيس استخبارات
الامريكي والذي بين من خلال تصريحات التي
صدرت عنه ان العمليه الهجوم المضاد
الاوكرانيه لابد انها ستاخذ وقتا كان هناك
تقارير صحفيه عن عزم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومن خلفها حلفاء اوكرانيا الى
كسب الوقت وتحقيق انتصار في هذا الهجوم
المضاد الذي المسمع القيام به خلال الاشهر
المقبله حتى تصل اوكرانيا الى نوع من
النصر يخولها الى دخول مفاوضات مباشره مع
الجانب الروسي ولكن هذه تصريحات حتى الان
لم يتم التعليق عليها من قبل الجانب
الاوكراني وان كنا قد سالنا بشكل مباشر
وزير الد الاوكراني في لقاء سابق وقال ان
اوكرانيا لا تفكر الان في اي في دخول اي
مفاوضات مع الجانب الروسي ميدانيا كان
هناك حديث عن تاكيد لعبور القوات
الاوكرانيه استمرار عبور القوات
الاوكرانيه الى الضفه اليسرى من نهر
دنيبرو المناطق التي تشغلها وتسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه كان هناك ايضا حديث من
هيئه الاركان عن استهداف لعده مناطق فيزا
وايضا في خرسون الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
ايضا تحدثت عن عجز في صفوف القوات الروسيه
من في من حيث انتاج القنابل الموجهه وقال
انها تعتمد على قناه
العهد السوفيتي تزن 500
كيلو غرام ولكنها غير موجهه وغير دقيقه
ولا تصيب اهدافها بشكل موثق نحن بانتظام
الزيارات كما ذكرنا لوصول رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني وايضا المؤتمر الصحفي وما سينتج
عنه من لقاءات بين الجانبين
شكرا كيف